le message se voulait fort les sept
présidents de départements des
départements d'île de france se sont
réunis hier pour évoquer l'avenir de la
métropole du grand paris alors que les
rumeurs s'intensifient sur le sujet et
que le gouvernement prévoit de faire 10
annonce importante d'ici un mois les
précisions de nicolas kirillovitch c'est
une image inhabituelle de la politique
francilienne les sept présidents des
départements de la région assis côte à
côte pour évoquer ensemble un souci
commun la métropole du grand paris ce
nouvel échelon territorial créée il ya
18 mois qu'ils soient des républicains
socialistes ou communistes
ils veulent tous modifier le schéma de
la métropole une collectivité qu'ils
estiment néfaste pour les habitants de
la grande couronne exclus du périmètre
actuel en 2017 dans la république
française on veut faire un mur entre la
métropole riche la métropole riches pour
les riches et puis la grande couronne
qui l a tous les ennuis c'est compliqué
de venir à paris en voiture
c'est compliqué de venir à paris en
transport en commun on se déplace pas ce
qu'on va chercher de l'emploi
nous avons une ambition plus grande
pourquoi parce que nous estimons que
c'est le bon échelon la région métropole
non seulement pour traiter les problèmes
de vie quotidienne de nos habitants mais
aussi
dans la compétition internationale pour
faire face au grand londres plus grandes
et plus puissantes pour les départements
de la grande couronne moins envahissante
pour ceux de la petite couronne
val-de-marne hauts-de-seine et
seine-saint-denis et s'inquiète eu des
rumeurs concernant une suppression de
l'échelon départemental au profit de la
métropole les projets je mets en oeuvre
aujourd'hui je le fais sur la base d'un
mandat démocratique qui m'a été confié
par les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis que chacun d'eux ce
qu'ils veulent
ce faire plus gros et bien fasse la
démonstration de ce soutien démocratique
ce n'est pas le cas je suis favorable à
une grande métropole à caractère
stratégique c'est-à-dire qu'il travaille
à l'attractivité de la région parisienne
dans son ensemble au plan international
mais pas à ce que la métropole du grand
paris s'occupe du ramassage des ordures
ménagères de la gestion des crèches de
des pmi directement mis en cause
l'exécutif prévoit d'organiser début
novembre une conférence autour de
l'avenir de la métropole du grand paris
est d'ici là les tensions elles
pourraient continuer de s'accroître et
pour être complet sur cette actualité
pierre bédier président du conseil
départemental des yvelines a confirmé
l'impossibilité pour le 78e 92 de
fusionner si la métropole du grand paris
reste dans ses frontières actuelles et
d'ailleurs pour continuer à se faire
entendre plusieurs départements
franciliens organise mardi prochain à
versailles une réunion publique en
présence du président du sénat gérard
larcher